After 20 years, I've learned the hard way
that there was never a good
time to withdraw US Forces.
How many more generations of
America's daughters and sons
would you have me send to
fight Afghanistan's civil war
when Afghan troops will not?
President Joe Biden's decision
to pull the United States
military out of Afghanistan
after two decades
has been roundly condemned
by interventionists
who say that the retreat was humiliating
and disastrously planned
leaving thousands of Afghans
prey to vengeance and violence
at the hands of the Taliban.
For Scott Horton and other
critics of US foreign policy,
the biggest question about the withdrawal
is what took so long?
Horton heads up the Libertarian Institute,
is editorial director at antiwar.com
and host the Scott Horton show podcast.
He's also the author of Enough Already
Time to End the War on Terror.
Recent talk with Horton about
why American intervention
in Afghanistan was doomed from the start
and how a libertarian
approach to both domestic
and foreign affairs would
make people better off
all over the globe.
Scott Horton, thanks
for talking to Reason.
Happy to be here.
Just before we started talking Joe Biden,
President Joe Biden
explained his rationale
for withdrawing from Afghanistan right now
and in the manner that he did.
What did you think of Biden's
defense of his policy?
I think it was perfectly reasonable.
I mean, I don't know what
else he was supposed to say
in the circumstances.
It's far too late to start
the war all over again
or anything like that.
If anything, you know, really,
the biggest weakness of his policy
has been that he broke
the deal essentially.
The deal that Donald Trump had signed
said, we will be out by May 1st.
And I think just for political reasons,
he didn't want it to
be Trump's withdrawal.
He wanted it to be his own thing.
And so he delayed that.
But that just gave the
Taliban this much more time
to take over the entire country
as America's on their way out the door.
So that's the reason
for the big scandal now
is we didn't get our decent interval.
We're supposed to be able to leave
and then they are supposed
to give us a few weeks
before embarrassing us this badly
by taking over the
whole country like this.
You know, let's get to
Biden in a second too.
You know, everybody in the
news it seems is talking about,
you know, this humiliation for America
and that, you know, we haven't
been this humiliated since,
you know, Vietnam in Saigon.
Do you, you know,
is that in any way,
shape or form accurate?
I mean, do you feel humiliated
by the American militaries
leaving Afghanistan
or do you think that's a proper way
to be assessing what's going on right now?
No, I think essentially
people are reacting
against what they assumed
was going to happen
which would be that the
Taliban would come in
and kill everybody
and that we'd have a horrible
black hawk down type disaster
as our guys try to get from
the embassy to the airport,
like some horrible
action movie or whatever.
But they haven't done that.
And the Taliban are,
they're obviously ruthless,
but oftentimes they
make rational decisions.
You know what I mean?
Doesn't mean that their policy
is always just crazy.
Essentially, they're not been modernized.
You know what it is?
I think people were thinking of
when ISIS took over Western Iraq
that it's gonna be like that.
But the Taliban really aren't
Bin Laden-like lunatics
like that.
They're very conservative
and extremely authoritarian
but they're not, you know,
revolutionaries really.
Yeah and I guess they're
effectively they're state actors.
I mean, you know exactly
who is in the Taliban now
and what the differences between
when it was actually running
Afghanistan before 9/11
or before the US invasion.
But you know, they were government,
they're not a non-state actors.
That's right.
For many years they've called themselves
The Islamic Emirate of Afghanistan.
And they've acted as a shadow government
from the American side's point of view.
But essentially as the
only real government
in much of the country for many years now.
And even David Petraeus
at the height of the surge
or at the dawn of the surge
I guess, back 10 years ago,
admitted that the Pashtun population,
especially in the south
and east of the country
and the predominantly Pashtun regions
that they vastly prefer
the Taliban system of
civil and criminal justice
to that imposed upon
them by the United States
and the new government
that we had set up there.
And so.
One of the arguments against Biden,
and I guess it's as much
against the, you know,
the last 20 years of American
presence in Afghanistan
is that the way that the
withdrawal happened was,
you know, clearly we, you know,
there were a lot of people
who thought they were gonna get out.
You know, there were,
one of the most disturbing
scenes I saw for, I guess,
was from over the weekend
were people were actually
hanging on to planes
as they were taking off.
CNN was showing a guy who
apparently fell from a plane
that was a couple of
hundred feet up in the air.
There is room to criticize the US
in the manner that it pulled out.
Is there?
Or where do you draw the
line on something like that?